welcome to this video mashooq dl who
very weird handle but it seems i haven't
played it before summer Rae I know the
name but it seems no games k got them
and Evans gambit well keep forgetting
how r this is played I always play it
with the d6 returning the pawn check
that's a very unassuming way to play it
I mean okay can can do that but it's not
very sort very ambitious let's say okay
Bishop to e6 maybe why not c6 Bishop g7
this kind of this kind of development
okay so it treats my problematic night
probably relying on the on the fact that
I hoping for for a center to be be
relevant it's got one extra porn in the
center and yeah definitely this is this
is so something something to play for ya
try to get the rook into the game
quickly with long castles and also cover
b7 Wow b5 I could / should be 6 coming
so just put should be six on I mean
Bishop c5 is awesome now come on let's
play actively why not attack the pawn I
can take a two now this was an idea
let's just grab it King be seven or
before let's start with King b7 spear
for meeeeee still somewhat fascinated by
the idea to play before when it could be
terribly wrong Joe the moment I don't
see what's wrong with it maybe no I
thought it can be take admission be to
look see to what I have bishop deform it
should be at least ok night a4 is a move
though Wow nine a 40 or what a howler
this I should have prevented definitely
hmm well no not good not good at all
yeah does that know this I totally miss
plate I really miss played it completely
Wow now now I'm just I'm just losing I
think that's not even it's not even in
some way playable be Wallace sighs this
is just just annihilating me really look
eh maybe I can somehow stay on the board
with that move ah how while be4 was
sterile from perfectly okay position I
think it wasn't necessary at all to do
that
Group C 2 coming F and it's it's bad
anyway input or okay three maybe look a
3d tried you maybe try to force the
street I mean it's blah it's a yuck
position anyway my king wide open
Luke 8 or something I don't know two
bishops bed structure the list goes on
and on look b-24 look hm maybe check
somehow I was still playing I really
thought it should be over by now but
maybe it wasn't so bad just very bad
okay so how do i connect somehow fight
rook to f8 is probably coming
it shades for or something check
yeah we can just take it I mean she
takes age for a while before was bad at
night afore I only saw it after I played
before this a single mistake was simply
unbearable position didn't didn't really
allow the disk error mistake to be made
could just take age form and I don't see
anything yeah that was just winning I
mean there was no big trick I don't know
what he thought for quite a while that
there is really no no particular
particular idea that
time warning
hmm Jim check
check Jerry its opposite color the
bishops yeah but still not really can I
really believe that it should be
something else than a loss check
yeah at least the sea poorness is going
and I wants to provoke f1 it's no
difference anyway but can check now at
least I can take but now I cannot stop
the porn so it's no big in any way black
there's a that it was just just I just
just played it terribly bad I mean yeah
I'm totally fine of course but maybe
this is this is already a kind of a
pseudo move fine something like that
it's just totally okay yeah I should do
that it's simply the better move here
the the dark squares are the possible
problem of my position and if I just go
there I mean this is just okay if no
problem can do this and just this is
just equal I mean I don't know maybe
black is even slightly better with the
two pawns supported by the king but I
can really never lose or anything and
here i I really don't know i mean this
is this is okay it's still okay but this
is this is just like a total level now
this before and he even could take out
whatever i mentioned but 9 a-4 it's just
luck yeah the comps SB 3 is equal yeah
yeah your computer you can you can play
those moves now maybe I have to simply
because alternatives are so terrible
that you have to play it it looks like
we are a it I so lates the bishop but it
is a strong it is a dangerous pawn yeah
whatever I did after taking and
basically toast jam maybe if there is
some tougher defense or anything we're
just a crack position really well okay
thanks for watching